>> Laura: TIME NOW FOR OUR
"DEFENDING THE FIRST" WHERE WE
DEFEND THE AMENDMENT, AND FREE
THOUGHT.
YOU ALL KNOW BEN SHAPIRO, AND IF
YOU DON'T, WHERE HAVE YOU BEEN?
HE'S BECOME ONE OF THE NATION'S
LEADING FIGURES IN THE EFFORTS
TO PRESERVE FREE SPEECH,
ESPECIALLY ON CAMPUS.
HE'S ALSO BEEN A FREQUENT TARGET
OF LEFTISTS FOR TRYING TO SHUT
DOWN HIS FREE SPEECH.
WHAT'S THE LATEST ATTEMPT?
I WAS WAITING FOR THIS.
THIS IS A CAMPAIGN TO BLAME BEN
SHAPIRO FOR INCITING A DEADLY
TERROR ATTACK ON A CANADIAN
MOSQUE LAST YEAR.
WE WELCOME BACK TO THE ANGLE,
BEN SHAPIRO.
THE EDITOR AND CHIEF OF THE
DAILY WIRE.
HE LOOKS SO UNASSUMING, AND WHAT
DO YOU WEIGH, LIKE 150 POUNDS?
>> 165, COME ON.
LAUGH     [LAUGHS]
>> Laura: WHAT YOU DON'T LOOK
LIKE ANYTHING.
EXPLAIN HOW YOU ARE ALLEGEDLY
INVOLVED IN INSPIRING THIS
HORRIBLE ATTACK ON A MOSQUE,
BECAUSE YOU MADE COMMENTS ABOUT
ISLAMIC TERROR IN THE PAST AND
IT WAS ALL STITCHED TOGETHER?
>> Ben: THERE WAS THIS EVIL
PIECE OF HUMAN THAT SHOT UP A
MOSQUE LAST YEAR AND HE HAPPENED
TO BE SOMEBODY THAT SAW SOME OF
MY TWEETS ON TWITTER.
HE HAD ALSO SEEN TWEETS FROM
PEOPLE, FROM YOU AND A BUNCH OF
DIFFERENT PEOPLE BUT I GUESS MY
ACCOUNT WAS THE ONE HE HAD
VIEWED THE MOST.
NOW I HAVE 1.4 MILLION TWITTER
FOLLOWERS SO IF SOMEONE VIEWS
ENOUGH OF MY TWEETS, THEY ARE
INEVITABLY GOING TO BECOME A
TERRORIST.
WE ARE THAT I DON'T HAVE A SPACE
OF ENORMOUS TERRORISM ACROSS THE
COUNTRY THANKS TO MY TWITTER
FOLLOWING, BUT NONE OF THIS IS
REAL.
PEOPLE ON THE RIGHT DID NOT SAY
THIS WAS BERNIE SANDERS' FAULT.